my name is Klaatu this is the talk on
programming with Lua in the love game
engine
this talk is meant for people who have
really zero programming experience
because I found that Lua is a great
training and teaching tool
arguably possibly easier to learn I
venture to say than even Python which
was kind of famously you know smooth to
kind of get into see what's on my sled
stuff I've done yes ok so I am a person
on the Internet
so I do internet things but I also do
tabletop things so one of the things
that I did last year was I ran a
Kickstarter and it failed so I did it
anyway and I designed a card game called
petition if you want to play this card
game hit me up after this talk because I
love playing it and need more people to
play it because only 20 people in the
world know that it exists
so petition game design blog I have a
game design blog at mixed signals ml and
I wrote a book on this the talk that I'm
giving right now there's a book version
of this called Lua on the Raspberry Pi
and I made sort of a short link it's a
redirect mixed signals ml / Lua it'll
take you to the a press publishing site
and you can purchase the book if you are
in charge of large installations of
books like a library purchase several of
them I need it so that's what I've done
before we get started actually I'm gonna
don't mistake this for an icebreaker
activity because I'm not I don't I like
ice I don't need it to be broken but
yeah you can do this do you can see me
play green shirts but you can still play
so take take one sheet of paper and pass
this pad of paper around please oh geez
that's yeah make sure everyone gets a
sheet and on that sheet I want you to
write a number 1 through 10 your choice
and then a win or lose condition is that
clear I said nothing more than a win or
lose condition so we're gonna make a
game together blindly so yeah do that
and I'm gonna give you watch time for it
we're not gonna we're not gonna resolve
this yet just make sure you get a piece
of paper write down a number one through
ten and then a win or a lose condition
okay so while you're doing that let's
talk about you a little bit so for
personal use Lua is really nice because
it is what is called strongly typed
which kind of means in practice that
it's really really consistent it tends
to be in my opinion quite predictable
there are little things in Lua that once
you learn one part of it then you can
almost guess the rest of it the same is
not true for some other programming
languages not to pick on Python but I
think Python sometimes can be a little
bit inconsistent you know like you'll
type something like if foo is bar or is
yeah is bar then do something and then
if you try I don't know if foo is more
than bar or greater than part it doesn't
know so it's like it tricks you into
natural language and then throws you
back out lua tends to just be pretty
straightforward i mean whether or not
it's friendly or whatever is a
completely different question I think it
is but it is consistent Lua does not
care about whitespace so if you're used
to languages that do care about
whitespace you do not have to worry
about that in Lua that is not a thing
that Lua cares about you can put as many
spaces or tabs or link lines Lua doesn't
care
Lua is also not an object-oriented
language it is it's basically a front
end to C but there are some really cool
tricks that you can do in Lua which
we'll talk about a little bit today
to mimic object-oriented actions and if
you don't know what that means that's
okay
it's just something for you to know for
the future Lua also uses a simple syntax
it is easy to remember I find and Lua is
really I think easy to teach there are
there are a couple of tricks in Lua that
once you learn them you basically know
Lua it's it's really kind of nice now if
you're a developer Lua is is really
simple for a programming language they
advertises that their manual is only a
hundred pages but I mean that's good
like if you think about as much has been
written about you know C or C++ or
Python like Lua fitting into a hundred
pages is kind of cool Lua is small it's
about twenty five thousand lines of C
code it is embeddable it runs in like
three hundred kilobytes of memory or
something ridiculous like that it's
portable because it's just written in
boring old C it's nothing fancy it's
just a really sort of minimal kind of
language and it's really easy to package
you can throw Lua and Lib Lua into your
package and you've you've just
distributed Lua it's it isn't there's
not a whole lot to it that's my
slideshow ok so now I'm gonna yes yep
Lua and love 2d is the 2d is the the
thing yeah so if if you're just joining
us you want to install Lua a package
called Lua which on whatever computer
you are using it might be apt install
Lua might be DNF install Lua and then
generally it'll give you a bunch of
choices and you can choose 5.1 you can
choose 5.2 you can chose 5.3 doesn't
really matter I am using five point one
point five that's what I've got on this
computer so if you want to mirror
exactly what I'm doing that's what you
would want to do and then love 2d is the
game engine that we're going to be using
to to give us graphics and that is the
more recent you can get the better
for for the for this talk we're gonna
keep it pretty simple we shouldn't run
into any issues if you have to fall back
on an old version I did run into some
problems on old versions when I was
doing like particle effects and stuff
but we're not going to do that right now
if you want particle effects by the book
there's all kinds of particle effects in
there tiling lots of cool stuff okay so
does anyone not have Lua and love to t
installed yet oh okay cool okay cool
love sorry it's not love TT it is love
2d technically on other on other places
yeah so the trick is if you're on a boon
to you can you can go to love to DS site
and get a PPA from from them that will
install a more recent version for you
which I mean it's not a horrible thing
to have so it might be worth it is the
pad of paper somewhere I would like to
write down a number and Oh end condition
myself
the peepee I think Oh did everyone does
anyone not have a piece of paper in
front of them with a number and they win
or a lose condition on it if you have no
idea what I'm talking about then that
means now did you not get one that's
okay I'll um I'll pass this sort of to
you and then you can pass it up over so
what we're doing is if you've missed if
you've missed anything we're writing
down a number one through ten on a piece
of paper and then we're right we're
writing a win or a lose condition and
whatever that means to you is what you
can base your answer on there's no right
or wrong that's the that's the good news
so that we all know that there's no
tricks I've written it down folded the
paper and I placed it under my box
petition which is available at the game
crafter calm slash whatever it's mixed
signals slash games slash petition ok so
let's get started then so I want to
start at the beginning with Lua and
we're going to just kind of jump right
into it really so the first thing that
you want to do probably is make a
project directory and your project
directory should more or less contain I
probably need to just make that white on
black and drop the green huh
you are ex there we go okay
get there
okay so you're making a directory and
you can call it whatever you want it's
gonna be a dice based game and it should
more or less contain these files you
don't have to put the credit in the
license but you want to make a directory
called font you want to make a directory
called image I do IMG so I don't know
the type as much and then eventually
we're going to make a file called
main.lua
so yeah more accurately your your
directory will contain font and image
right now
now the love 2d engine is pre-programmed
so so I should I should back up actually
even more so Lua is the programming
language right so that's what we'll be
typing we'll be typing Lua commands Lua
program and that Lua program will be
interpreted by a game engine called love
the game engine is just a bunch of
libraries sort of pre-programmed to
respond to specific commands from you so
rather than having to write the code for
therefore to display an image on screen
we're going to just say display an image
on screen love will interpret that
command and display images on screen for
us love is pre-programmed to look for a
file called main.lua so there's nothing
Louis specific about the the filename
may ánewá but there is something love
specific to mein dalawa in other words
to make this really short and simple if
you're programming something in the love
for the love game engine you want your
your file that's going to be executed it
needs to be called main.lua
okay so I'm going to open up a file
called main.lua in a text editor and the
first thing I'm going to do is I'm going
to do a hash exclamation mark slash user
USR slash bin slash env Lua space Lua
strictly speaking it's not necessary for
the love game engine to see that it does
make things nice though it's a good
habit to get into
okay so one of the nice things about
love is that it enforces a structure
onto your program that's not necessarily
great for the rest of your life but
certainly as you're learning this may
actually really make it easy to kind of
understand what what you have to do to
get a program that sort of makes sense
so we're going to make three sections to
our code and this is really honestly
this is not a horrible thing to do for
whatever you're writing I I kind of I
stole this this this model from Lua when
I'm teaching Python now because it's
it's a really really sane way of
structuring a program so we're gonna
make three sections and we'll just leave
them empty right now but they need to
exist so might as well make them now one
is called function love dot load and
then at the end of the below that put
the word end so a function does anyone
know what a function is yeah so a
function is some code that is kind of
packaged into a recipe that you can then
call later on to run it over and over
again so you don't have to keep writing
the same code so function love dot load
is the part of your code that when
someone launches the love game engine
that's gonna happen first the next
function that we're gonna make is called
love dot draw anyone guess what that's
gonna do yeah it draws whatever people
will see on the screen so that means
because this is a motion image right
it's it's a video game so it's
refreshing constantly so this function
is
anything you put into love draw is gonna
happen like like every millisecond it
happens over and over and over and over
again which is good because possibly you
want some you want it to refresh you
want something - you want some animation
in there and I think that's I think
we're gonna stick I think we'll we'll
just keep with those two functions first
so one to load everything in and then
one to continue drawing lots and lots
so we're gonna try to get something on
screen pretty quickly here just so you
see how these things interact with one
another and so the first thing that
we'll do if a computer is going to draw
a window on the screen what do you think
some of the attributes that it would
want to know would be size of the window
right so we can we can define that and
for reasons that I won't necessarily go
into right now I'm gonna do that above
the love dot load function they're going
to get loaded in and and then loved by
Lua and then love will execute the love
dot load function you can put it in love
load it's okay to do that I think I
haven't done it in a while but it's it's
sort of best to leave it outside and I'm
just gonna i'm using CW and CH for
canvas width and canvas height and I'm
gonna make it fairly small here
okay so now the big question is if we
want to draw something well so let's
let's see what that would happen let's
let's just try this let's let's save
what we have okay saved it and now from
from my terminal from within the
directory does everyone does that you
would not know how to get to their
project directory in a terminal that's
fine so the way that you're going to do
that where did you make your directory
where is it
I don't believe you I think you're lying
to me I still I don't think you're there
so where's your directory do you yeah do
you have a terminal open okay
so do a yeah do do a PWD and tell me
where you are right now which which is
what PWD will tell you
where that's what I'm thinking yeah so
you're you're in your home directory
right now and you've made a project
directory they're in your home directory
or can you make one okay make a yeah
make a directory in your home directory
so I should have been more clear about
that make take that directory and put it
into your home and then once that is
there do a CD and then a tilde slash
whatever your directory was called so
maybe it's dice demo or whatever you
called it then you will be then you will
be your there fantastic
anybody else anybody else I want this to
work I'm more interested in this working
than not talking cool all right if
you're not telling me you don't know
where you are then that's on you okay
so now we'll type in from that directory
so as long as you do a PWD and you get
back the path to the demo directory that
you made we're gonna just type in love
and then a dot love space dot that means
run love within this folder oh okay yeah
so love to t dot possibly and you should
ideally get that she isn't super
exciting but but there you go okay
you might you might see errors about
like the jack server not being started
that's not an error that's just a
warning it's just because we're not
we're not utilizing the audio system
that that it thinks we might want to use
what that sure so and that that's good
because actually I don't know where my
stupid command has Mac's Dutch and oh
you mean okay so what we're doing here
this is this is pretty much all you need
right now to get that wonderful blank
window that we got this is your this is
your source code and so what we're doing
does anyone have any idea who does
anyone who's maybe hasn't programmed all
that much have any idea what what we are
really doing here up at the three yeah
we're setting a variable so all it does
everyone I'm going to tell you what a
variable is now instead of asking a
variable is like a box and boxes like to
have things in them so in programming
languages we're allowed to make any
number of boxes then that we want
they're called variables we can just
make them for free we just get to just
call them whatever and usually the
syntax not always but usually the syntax
is something like hey here's a variable
name that I just made up equals and then
whatever you want to put into the box
so box here's some data that I wanted to
put into the box now it's there in the
variable and then anytime you want to
refer to the contents of the box you
just call the Box name and the
programming language knows what you're
talking about
so those are variables you've made your
first variables now so we have set a
width and a height this is a little bit
a little bit taller than wide but that's
because I'm kind of having it in mind
for a mobile phone so I figure people
will probably play my little game this
way so that's that's why I chose those
those dimensions
okay so I think we're oh yeah
yeah that's true I'm not sure why that
is it should have looked correct
quite possibly yeah
okay so now we're gonna put stuff into
into our into our code and I'm gonna
start throwing out a bunch of like
things at you that aren't gonna make a
whole lot of sense or they'll make sense
while I'm telling you and then you'll
walk away later and you'll think you
know what that guy was totally not cool
because he was just throwing names at us
and how do i how am I ever gonna
remember that stuff I have an answer for
that so if you want to type that while I
tell you the answer why are these things
not showing up there's oh I know why
here let me just switch to text mode
there we go that's better yeah so so
things like love dot window dot set
capital T for title and then the name of
my game love dot window dot set mode all
that stuff oh there's some stuff that's
not on the right line there that's
getting cut off there we go nope well
not for this purpose
and yeah so these these things here
these magical settings that I'm just
kind of using without explaining what
they are where they come from those come
from love from the game engine so those
are those are functions just like we've
written here function love dot load
they're they're functions of their own
now those functions aren't in our code
because they exist in the love game
engine code so when you installed the
love game engine you installed Unknowing
to yourself the all these other
functions these love dot window
functions and stuff like that so oh and
there you go
yeah and that's why the the size wasn't
correct right because we didn't we
haven't set a mode of the window so in
this case what we're doing is we're
we're telling love when it's loading and
remember I said the first thing it does
is look it looks for a function called
love
so we're telling it hey I want you to
call the window dice and I want you to
set some set the mode of the window
which is just what you know the way that
they chose to express that we're going
to now sort of control how the window
looks so I'm gonna someone have that
typed in okay I mean we'll come back to
it anyway so so actually I wouldn't have
to even do that I should just leave that
open I should leave it in text mode and
then oh no okay so T MUX doesn't know
how to do that I can never mind so then
we're gonna do a love dot again and now
look at the window OOP not that window
this window there you go that looks a
little bit more like that sure does yeah
pretty good okay so does that make sense
to everybody and look at the title dice
so whatever you called your whatever you
used for the set title that's what
inherited that that's where that value
came from so I really hate when when
learning a programming language or
teaching a programming language when all
these special things start coming out
and you're just just like well how am I
ever gonna remember how do I even ever
find out that that there's such a thing
as love that window dot set title and
the way that you find out is you go to
your web browser and you look up
neither can I actually there we go
you look up love to do org and you go to
the wiki in this case
and see see here on the left there's all
these love dot themes those are all the
cool things that you can do with love
now not all of them are gonna mean
anything to you yet but that is where
you find out what they expect to receive
from you and and what's available to you
so I don't know how do you play audio in
a love game probably the love audio
function the library and yeah sure
enough there's a bunch of stuff so wind
out just go to the documentation and
just look at the the reference of all
the different libraries that will have
has for you and then you can you can do
stuff okay so the real power of Lua may
as well get to it right now are what
call are the real power is what is
called a table a table in Lua is what
other programming languages call an
array arra why I don't know if there
might be some technical differences I
don't really know like you know I
haven't looked at the code that
constructs all these things but but
that's they're basically the same thing
so if you've ever used an array in any
programming language we're probably in
math then it's it's the same thing and
Lua tables unlock really about 80% of
the language to be honest
including the stuff like the
object-oriented sort of mimicking so
here's a comment in Lua not a text mode
again two dashes and some words as a
comment so Lua ignores anything after
two dashes so I'm gonna do two dashes
and I'm just gonna kind of make note
that this is setting the screen size I
could say set screen size that way when
we look at this later we'll remember oh
yeah that's what that did so now we're
going to create some tables so create
tables and I think what we'll do is
we'll call
one local Dave equals curly brace curly
brace and the other one's gonna be local
how equals curly brace curly brace now
you don't know why that's cool yet but
but tables are really great and here's
one of the reasons how can I demonstrate
this quickly so Lua uses tables to
describe a variable or at least that's
how we're using it so in other words we
want to players in our little dice game
that we're that we're building together
and so one is gonna be days and one is
gonna be how one's going to be the
computer and one's gonna be the human at
the controls each of them will have
different aspects to them since they are
each a table we can just throw variables
into their tables and that way we're
building kind of our players it is
exactly like an array yeah yeah so if we
do for instance so if we do let's do
this will be a little bit funky because
of an update to love it's kind of
annoying but that's okay so we're gonna
do a local dot Dave
dave dot color rather local space dave
dot color and we're going to define it
as a set of numbers and this is kind of
where it gets ugly
actually sorry we don't need the the
local there I'm just Dave color equals
and then a bunch of numbers so these
numbers are RGB values this is so the
way that love expresses colors have
changed and being from a video
background I kind of associate color as
0 through 255 shades of some value RGB
so this is how I write it you can also
write it as a decimal from 0 to 1 so 0.2
0.3
I can't think like that so I I take what
I want to write and then just divide it
by 255 so sorry you can just copy these
numbers if you are familiar with how
HTML colors work this is basically the
same thing if you take a hex code break
it into two three sets of two-digit
numbers you can just kind of set that
you can turn up the R and dial down the
G and up the blue and you'll get purple
and so on so those are those are numbers
and they're gonna represent a color I
[Music]
want to say yes to that
yeah I don't I can't think of any time
that I've ever had to do anything
special for it so copying in the wrong
values hopefully you're not copying me
probably you are cuz I'm giving the talk
okay there we go
that'll do that'll do
alright so I'm gonna do something now to
sort of reinforce a couple of things
you'll thank me for momentarily alright
so I'm gonna I'm gonna paste this one in
and this note that this is in the love
dot load function so that means that
when we launch love this is going to get
loaded right away and it is using the
graphics library for love so it's love
dot graphics and then within that
library it's using the set background
color with a capital B in a capital C
set background color no you in color set
background color and then it gives it
again some of those weird numbers that I
like to use to me it's perfectly clear
what's that yes yeah yeah absolutely
yeah you definitely want to do the set
background color so we probably can
guess what that's going to do so let's
test it and I mean though
maybe I'll test it separate from you so
that I don't have to take that screen
away while I do it
so if you do a love dot in your in your
project directory right now you should
see that or a syntax error could could
could see that anyone else got a syntax
error yep oh wait there's the code no
it's the same sorry there you alright so
this is in the love dot load function it
could be I don't feel like it should be
do you have curly braces around the
colors yeah no that's fine yeah what
always right now
yeah sorry I did that initially by
accident sorry to confuse you yeah once
we've established that the variable
exists we just call the variable by name
we just there's a variable called Dave
and then we can just call it Dave
so in fact I'll even put a little
comment here just to kind of separate it
out from everything else both players
there we go yeah no I didn't apparently
so any more syntax errors or we all
seeing a green
okay just for for for fun try moving it
this whole thing into I'm just curious
as to what will happen into the draw
function are you guys what version of
love are you on out of curiosity 9 okay
that could be could be the weight you're
on know someone you're on nine aren't
you yeah oh sorry no I heard a voice and
decided that even though the person whom
I was speaking to his mouth wasn't
moving I just decided that he was the
one talking the person right behind you
you're online or did you okay love in
general okay that's too bad
yeah okay okay interesting yeah so we'll
see there's nothing it's just not not
rendering it correctly
that is interesting we'll have to see
yeah what I mean hopefully that will not
persist through the whole project I
don't remember ever encountering that
particular issue you know what it might
be
I'll bet I'll bet it is me I'm running
both 11.1 or something so I'm gonna I'm
gonna go I'm gonna go to the no yeah
that's not know that it's
it's the RGB values okay so instead of
hey everybody I figured something out
so move move your background thing back
to the love dot load and then instead of
my wacky numbers just drop the / - five
five just give it in this case 25 comma
125 comma 75 yeah because I forgot or I
didn't forget but I didn't make that
connection that as of I think 11 ish
they decided for whatever reason to go
from 0 to 1 with 0 being yeah so so
that's what's happening so cool I hope
this has been a valuable lesson to
everyone about debugging but yeah
exactly that bad - that ok cool so is it
so is anyone there's anyone feeling
totally lost I mean I know someone's
having an issue with installing but is
everyone else
approximately near by where I am
okay what that's what I was yeah yeah
okay okay
so it's it's the display server rather
than anything else yeah okay yeah that's
too bad it's okay well we'll keep going
then so we know how to create it create
a background color that's great
so now we will you kind of have to do
like math sort of in your head so it's
like so 225 is pretty low weight like if
you picture it as a color mixer 25 would
be pretty low on the red the green would
be pretty sort of in the middle so if
you want so if you want it all lighter
than you need to dial everything up
equally so instead of 25 125 75 maybe
you would do math like 35 135 85 that
would do it by like that much but yeah
okay
oh yes yeah absolutely yeah so so for
Dave and how colors you also need to
drop the / 255 so if you're on version 9
or whatever none of your numbers should
have a / 255 because you're you're using
a traditional what for me what a
traditional RGB scale would look like
not for the love developers
okay so we're gonna have to do some some
legwork now because we want to actually
get like a game going so what we're
going to do is try to find some graphics
and is everyone a little is anyone not
online right now cool okay so I'm gonna
I'm gonna throw some graphics on a
website real quick
I'm yeah I'm all for it I'm all for it
[Music]
okay so if everybody if everybody goes
to trying to figure out how to convey a
URL quickly to you I'll just type it
into the code
don't don't type this get images from
HTTP colon slash slash slacker media dot
info / tank slash stuff dot zip you
should be able to W get it or just go
there and a website web browser and it
should start downloading and that's
gonna have some images and some fonts
there's nothing special about these
images and fonts they are free content
that I got from open clipart org which
is a fantastic website if you need
graphics you know for for practically
anything they're just it's a great site
and also fonts from font library org I
think so yeah that makes sense I mean
maybe I did it wrong it does work
I should know the curl command but I
don't I can put it on a thumb drive
probably yeah so unzips unzip that
folder and put the images into the IMG
folder and the fonts in the font folder
oh cool
Wow that's fancy yeah so if they're not
there put them there
and you should see some fonts and some
images in your directory this is an
important concept if you're if you're if
you do web design at all then you're
this is probably old hat to you but if
not it's really really important for
your own sanity too when you're building
a project whether it's a web project a
love game that you're programming a
video production music product anything
that you are working on you should have
a project directory and then in that
project directory you should be copying
everything that needs to live with that
project into that project folder really
that way when you archive it later
you'll have everything that you need
it's like a self-contained unit that's
particularly important for this because
the end result of all this is that
you're going to package everything up
that's in your project directory and if
your fonts and your images aren't in
there then your game is not going to
work so so if you want to add to hazard
a guess how do you think and pseudocode
is acceptable here how do you think we
would assign a default image to
represent Dave or how pseudocode is
perfectly acceptable so you can just
sort of make stuff up but how how would
we do that if you want
set image maybe yeah yeah but what so
what no no don't look don't look at the
mail no wait
do look at the manual what am I talking
about that's great someone just wanted
to look at a manual love thought
something something said something now
what - what variable would will be
assigned this something anyone have a
notion that's what that would look like
so
something wait what
not local I lied about local we set
local once and we don't ever have to say
that again so Dave Dave Dave dot tick
right okay yeah okay because remember in
in in love when you make a table and
that's what these things are those
little curly braces at the very top when
you make that you can then sort of
expand on it as much as you want
with a dot and then whatever word you
want to use so if we want to assign a
default image to a variable we could say
okay dave dot i don't know give me a
word that would make sense in this
instance image I do IMG because typing
is just not in and then we could say
it's going to equal and then we need to
look up the the function for this does
anyone look that up
love dot graph fix dot what was it new
image and then parentheses parentheses
and then the full the full path of the
not full path but like the path of the
image which since we're in our project
directory
is IMG and then slash and then whatever
name of the image that we want to use
which in this case will just use dye one
PNG that is it should be inside correct
yeah we could try no I don't think I
don't think it would work up there
because we want love itself
love it love is going to look at the
function love dot load so stuff that
works
you were telling directly to love we
want it to be inside that function no
cool okay great yeah it's like habit
versus what will actually work sometimes
they're completely different things so
now we can do we can use the same exact
logic for well actually let's not do
that yet let's just save that let's
launch see what happens does anyone have
a guess as to what's gonna happen OOP
that's the wrong one
what's that no I know correct
okay so the problem is that we've
declared this thing that we got right
out of the manual it should totally work
why wouldn't this work well the problem
here is that we've we've we've declared
something but then we haven't actually
drawn it on the screen and remember love
is only going to draw what we have
see that the problem I'm having is that
I'm cheating a lot by using something
that's you know like on those cooking
shows where they're all everything's
already prepared and I'm just I'm not I
[Laughter]
know okay so you may have gotten a green
screen that's fine let's let's figure
out how to draw this thing on on our
screen like a dye
now this is going to be a little bit
this is gonna be a lot of stuff to type
and it's not necessarily going to all be
pretty but we'll try it first so we'll
do a love so this is this is in the this
is in the draw function and we're doing
love dot graphics dot draw and then the
first thing that we need to do is tell
it what to draw now this is a little bit
confusing because you might think well
we want to draw a slash image slash diet
one PNG right well no we want to draw
the thing that is set to that so we just
you we reference that variable and
that's a pretty common thing in
programming we're just because that's
how it works you have to you you you use
the function whose job it is to go find
a file and once that's done you've
assigned it to a variable and so then
when you when you want to actually use
the image you use a different function
whose job it is to refer to the location
of the file and then to draw it on the
screen when to use one and not the other
can be a little bit confusing at first
because you might think you know you
might think that you just want to do one
thing but yeah so I don't know how to
tell you to learn that other than just
to look up those functions in the docs
and and see what it tells you to do and
then maybe somewhat predictably we want
to do things like let's put it maybe
sort of halfway down the sort of in the
middle of the screen more or less so
that's the canvas width divided by two
and then we'll do the canvas height
divided by two and all of this stuff
again this isn't just me like just
making up stuff to put into the
parentheses this is all in the
documentation for this function so if
you're thinking if you're sitting down
you know after this and thinking crap
I'm gonna try to make a game
I remember there was something about
drawing some stuff in the function love
draw go look at the documentation maybe
do a search on the internet you know how
to draw something on screen in love 2d
and and it will tell you what all of
these values are I don't even remember
there's there are so many values that
this accepts I'm just gonna put a bunch
of zeros in and see what happens
what's up no I think there's actually
more because there's no that's not it
yeah because there's like scaling and
rotation and a bunch of other stuff so
yeah let's
yeah so here's the values that I had
0.04 0.04 and then 0 0 that should do it
maybe that's just scale the died down so
if you put like if you don't have that
in there then the dice are to be huge
because they're just really really big
yeah they're like huge - oh right here
ok that's not even all on the screen let
me try to get that on the screen there
we go
cool
what that they are they should be up at
the very yet the very top of your file
you will have defined a local CW equals
some number and in local CH here I'll
dive up there real quick and people can
review their work see you right there
keep doing
so possibly you're getting something
that looks like that yeah cool
all right it's good it's good feel like
we've made progress what time is it and
how okay I think I'm gonna actually even
simplify this further it may be less of
a competitive game and a dice roller
game we'll see we'll see how far we go
but let's let's shoot first for a dice
roller so it won't be a game it'll just
be a handy d6 roller for you so I'll see
the first thing for that we would need
to do is well we're gonna need some
numbers right I mean every that that's
what we need right so take out some
comfort die here so how can we get a
random number on a computer does anyone
have any ideas people who haven't done
this before people who haven't done this
before anybody you have an idea
I don't believe nobody has an idea where
could we get a random number in real
life like if we were looking around the
room and we needed a number like right
now
where could we get one what's that sure
so how would that be like maybe by Row 1
2 3 and then see 1 2 3 so we could count
count on a matrix what else there's a
really common source of numbers that we
refer to in fact I just referred to it
myself
in form of a question that but that was
way before time a clock right so
computers have clocks and we can kind of
tap into that yes I mean it's super easy
do I have a no I don't I don't know how
to do anything in tea mugs ok that's
fine we'll skip over it it's super easy
and bash if you're
terminal and you just type in the word
date you'll get like a number and if you
do a date I think plus % s lowercase s I
think that epoch time you'll get a
really long string of single of really
long string of digits that if you keep
doing it up up inter up inter up in sure
it'll change constantly it's ticking all
the time so this is a pretty good source
of of I say pretty good it's like a an
acceptable sometime source of random
numbers in a computer and the way that
that works in law in Lua actually is yes
it's good I'm gonna stop scolding people
for reading the manual geez people are
angry now because it's not random enough
don't worry this is it's a d6 roller
we're gonna be fine
so if you do math dot random seed OS dot
time parentheses parentheses then what
you're doing is you're telling Lua to
establish to kind of switch on this sort
of awareness of okay I'm gonna need a
random number so whenever I need that
I'm gonna do some calculations based on
like right now whatever time I get back
from my computer and I'll I'll do fancy
things and then give you a number back
and admittedly it is not super random
like I was doing tests for a different
project last night and I was trying to
get I was trying to get some probability
of dice rolls and it was just a joke it
was it was ridiculous it was clearly not
accurate so it's not great but it works
for our purposes so we establish this
random seed in the love.load function
and then we will use that random seed in
our draw function to figure out what to
draw on the screen
so let's do a what are we using we're
using Dave right we're just we're doing
the human stuff and don't this there we
go yeah so we draw a Dave constantly
that'll probably have to change so what
we're gonna do instead is we're going to
invoke this random function that we've
created this random seed and we're gonna
get a number from it and the way that
you do that yes the thing is so all
right so we need to tell love slash Lua
like we need to say hey I want a number
now I want a random number and we want
we want what do we want to have trigger
that what on a phone what would you
expect to how would you get a number
like a dice number on a phone like it's
probably just a tap or something right
so that's basically a mouse click like
this on a phone is a mouse click so we
really we don't want to put our little
call of randomness in our draw function
because what does the draw do it repeats
every millisecond right we don't want
that many random numbers we just want it
on on demand so there happens to be a
nice little function in love for this
very purpose and it is called function
well we can we can use it by by calling
function love's dot Mouse released Y
released and not something like I don't
know pressed correct we want it gonna be
when we that would give us a random
number for as long as we held the button
down that's not what we want we want the
button we want the one number and the
one event that we can track is when we
do that so
I mean there are times where you may
want to use the press a mouse press and
in fact in the in the bigger version of
this little game I have some audio
playing so that if people hold down the
mouse key then audio starts like you're
powering up the dice and then you
release it you feel like you've done
something special and it is all illusory
okay so when that happens we're gonna do
we're gonna do a we're gonna get a
random number what do we want to do with
a random number does anyone know cuz
remember computers they can't track
what's up
okay so first we're gonna save it
because if we grab it here when it's
released then we need to take a snapshot
and computers can't keep track of
anything unless you put it in a box
variable so what would be a good
variable name for Dave's role Dave wait
what Dave what who Dave dice or Dave dot
dice dot dice remember in lua tables we
have a table called dave we established
that way up here right so in order to
throw stuff into that table we just put
a dot and then some word and and like I
say it can it can be any word so if not
that that's the one thing it cannot be
so Dave dot dice equals right because
that's how we set a variable and then we
need to use a math I mean a Lua function
called math dot and we just invoke it
with random loop random and we need to
give it a range and the way that Lua
expresses ranges in this context is
comma different programming languages do
it differently you'll see it you know
whatever but in this case that's in Lua
that's how you do it so you're saying
okay I want you to get that
and I want you to invoke the random seed
to get a number but I want you to
constrain that number between one and
six that's probably I mean that's that's
not a whole lot to work with and and
maybe rolling a d20 would have been
better but we're doing D six because
that's the image that I found so correct
I think it'll actually just fail
silently No
well isn't that okay okay so okay I'm
gonna comment it out right now and we're
gonna test
oh wait that won't work anyway nevermind
we'll just take it on faith right now
that in some in one way or another if
you had not started the random seed
either you would get the same number
back every time where you would fail
silently it's gonna feel approximately
the same because it's not going to
change okay so now we do have a number
and when we when we get the number we
want it to be reflected in the dice
image right that's that's the goal here
we want to we want to see what we got
you might think well let me ask you what
you think where do you think we would
redraw where would we put this new image
how could we define now let's say we
rolled the six and we've got Dave deep
by default is dye one right so how do we
tell it weird where do we tell it yes
okay
so yep I know actually well I mean okay
so I think you're actually kind of
saying the same thing so what I think
it's saying here is we're saying okay so
we're gonna say that now that we have a
random number we are going to then over
override what we've already told love in
the beginning
Dave's image is so we're gonna say Dave
image is now instead of dye one dot PNG
we're gonna say that it's love dot
graphics dot new image and then the path
to the dye but here's where it gets
tricky so we don't know what random has
gotten it's gotten a number one through
six how do we know what image to load
oh you could do that actually yeah okay
I like that yeah yeah okay so but that's
a great way to do it but this is really
good because this is something that
you're going to be doing in lua
a lot which is concatenating data and
and really in programming a lot of times
you're you're doing things like this so
in lua if you want to put two things
sort of together it is for whatever
reason two dots I'm gonna give myself a
little bit more room here so what we're
saying is that the new image is going to
be just in the same old image location
and then slash die and then close the
quote and then dot dot meaning don't
stop here I'm going to give you a
different other value and we're going to
refer to the value as dave dice cuz
that's what we named it right Dave's out
dice has some number we don't know what
it is so put it there and then again
don't stop he keep keep going and then
it ends in dot PNG so we're basically
telling it I want you to kind of
construct a file path for me and that
file path should contain image slash die
whatever's in Dave dice and then dot PNG
I think okay so I think what's happening
here is that love is probably protecting
us from that okay okay all right fair
enough I'm gonna leave it like that
nevertheless right now because I'm on a
time limit but I will I will keep that
in mind in the future so if you let's
see where we're at now
so if you launch your little program and
click with your virtual finger you
should be seeing your dice change is
anyone not seeing that yeah
where are you the sign what are you to
assign each image well it doesn't and
that's probably why it's not the
greatest format so we're just telling it
take where we're constructing a path
from from whatever yeah yeah which is
then passed to yeah yeah
but you've got a green background is
anyone else on nine not and not seeing
the die what's that okay
what was it was it just the series of
yeah that's a lot of zeros for anybody
you're saying to put another line in
here where you're formatting where
you're converting the the value yes sir
go for it
oh wait this is a Dvorak keyboard wait
wait wait
there you go this will work sort of and
the return key isn't actually the return
key so what is it
it's the backslash or the pipe so it's
just like a printf style thing is
usually the easiest way to do it I am
good observation Corky yeah I think that
should be standard yeah so that's one
way to do it oh that's great yeah auntie
doesn't work anywhere presenter no this
one that one yeah
yeah I don't want to really necessarily
go into that yeah all right yeah that's
yeah I liked that idea but yeah I don't
want to get too deep into that right now
so yeah cool there you go we've
formatted using a I don't know what are
those called not variables string format
I guess converting this yeah and if if
mr. Lua over here says that that the
other way is unsafe I would rather do it
this way so you want to copy that that's
fine
okay so I think we I think we probably
have time I feel like we probably have
time to do a little bit of sound because
I want to kind of make this more than
just just graphics so we are I think I
think I still have what
oh no we're almost done aren't we it's a
3:30 or okay yeah then we don't really
have time for sound necessarily okay all
right let's try it okay so it isn't hard
that's the good news
in fact you could probably honestly kind
of figure it out on your own so what
we're going to do is we're going to use
oh you messed up my keyboard cuz now
it's in us there we go now it's better
yeah it's better well I still have to
blame you okay so everything's working
better now so what we're gonna do is
we're gonna define the variable up at
the top and we're gonna call it what do
they call it here I'm gonna call it
Rumble cuz no actually yeah yeah or
tumble let's call it tumble and we're
gonna give it us it's similar to
defining a new image except that instead
of an image it's not that it's audio I
think love audio dot new source so it's
a lot like the new image new or the
graphic dot new image it's just a source
of audio and it's pretty much I don't
think I've actually distributed the
sound to you so we're gonna have to
distribute that so we'll do sound dot
dice dot OGG comma
stream and actually for consistency I'm
going to just convert these to single
quotes because I think that's what I've
been using so better yeah it looks
I don't know if strictly this next one
is necessarily necessary in this case
because I forget what the default is but
I'm going to put it in anyway because
it's something that's that's good to
know about so we're gonna just do we're
going to use the same variable name and
we're going to tell love to set looping
as false and that is simply I think it
defaults to not looping anyway but I'm
gonna put it in there because that way
you you'll remember that there's an
option to loop of sounds so if you have
a background music or something like
that then you could set looping to true
and then it would just keep playing that
sound you know yeah yeah yeah okay so so
that has established the variable so
hopefully you're seeing a pattern here
we kind of set up some variables and
then we start using them in the code and
that's that's kind of pretty typical and
then where do we want to trigger this
sound do we think do we want it in the
draw method the load method where would
we want this what's up yeah oh yeah and
it's hard for you actually to answer
this because you haven't heard the sound
yet so actually in this case I want it
on the release again because it's going
to be the sound of that so we just want
that to happen once and playing a sound
is as easy as triggering it by saying
love audio dot play and then telling it
what sound to actually play now you
don't have this sound yet so let me -
out to my master directory here and I'm
gonna secure copy this file to
Oh a syntax error oh yeah that could be
yeah could be
yeah I forgot to bundle the sound I'm
putting that onto a website right now
okay so if you guys W get slacker media
dot info / tank / dice dog
oh no sorry just tank this should just
be a tank like that grab that and put
that in a in a folder called s in D for
sound
try that out see if that works
cool yeah great
all right I mean no I meant that
sincerely sorry cool great great you're
a programmer now all right so I do need
to cover one more thing and that is how
to get this thing into a format that
people can use you're you're kidding but
it's really really close to what we're
about to do let me grab my sound file
here can you see this are you seeing us
yet okay cool
all right so we've got a directory this
is your project directory still and
you're you probably want to do this in a
terminal I would do it in a terminal so
what we're gonna do is we're gonna do a
zip and actually this might not work on
Mac OS yeah anyway it zip let's call it
dice dice roller dice roller dot and
that we're gonna call it zip because I
think some zip tools will get really
confused if you try to create something
that's not called a zip and then we're
going to do a dash R for recursive which
means hey if you find a direct if you
come across a directory grab all the
stuff in the directory that's what
recursive means and then font image and
then main and sound so all everything in
the folder pretty in this directory
pretty much so what we're doing here is
we're we're using the zip command to
create a new archive called dice roller
zip and we're saying all of these things
here that's what we want to put into
that archive you
two minutes two minutes and then so now
we've got a dice rollers if we are going
to rename that within the tool command
rather and we're gonna call it instead
advice - rollers if and this you could
actually probably do in a file manager
we're gonna call it a love so the dice
roller dot love and and if you do that
on your machine you may even see that
the icon changes it'll change from like
a generic zip archive to a little love
icon probably I think it probably
depends on the zip tool but I I'm pretty
sure I've run into problems with it I
feel like I have I feel like zip itself
is pretty picky about that yeah what I'm
yeah what I usually do is make a little
make file that just does all that stuff
for me and then I don't have to bother
rather than yeah yeah so now that that
package right there is it's a love file
and if you send it to a friend and say
hey if you need to roll the d6
you should use this really not very
random application that I wrote and then
they'll be as long as they download look
the love package and install it they'll
be able to do that they'll be able to
they do not need new uh per se they just
need to get loves like whatever process
they get loved by the everything will be
self-contained in there and that
includes Android phones so if you go to
love to die org and install love from
the site and I say that significantly
because the Play Store has an older
version then you'll be able to play your
just pretend like this is on the screen
really big you'll be able to play your
little dice
stroller on your phone just as you are
on your screen so it's a pretty easy way
really to get a nice and quick little
app on a phone without having to like go
through the whole Android the apk or the
SDK for Android and stuff like that the
love application on Android is a little
bit it's not quite perfect yet there's
like no way to choose your files so you
have to sort of tell your Android phone
hey when you see a love file open it in
this in this application so it's not
it's not perfect but they're still
working on it
it is technically available for iOS as
well but from the instructions that I
saw you you pretty much have to compile
it for iOS and it looked like Xcode and
stuff like that so probably not
something that most of your users would
be doing that's everything that I have I
think so and actually part of the part
of the paper thing was we were going to
we were going to randomize some numbers
so I guess I guess I'll do that really
quick but you don't have to follow along
on this one
no I think it was this one
Oh 2 1 2 6
no 1 to 10 I said right ok
so paper time anyone who wrote down the
number 2 what is your win or lose
condition that you wrote down along with
2 no one wrote down two yeah aren't they
though
how about the number 5 anybody wrote
down 5 5 minutes left how about the
number 8 people did understand the
instructions ok yes what what what win
or lose condition did you write down is
the loser of the winner so if if 8 or
above you win but lower you lose okay so
who has been excluded from winning at
this point in if you do not do 8 or
above you have lost the game at this
point you you lost all right so remember
okay so remember that so number 4 who's
who's 4 okay what was your win or lose
condition of 4 wins so that means he can
still win and what else was it okay but
for exactly what happens 4 or less you
lose okay so you lost yourself like you
explicitly wrote into your okay that's
fine I didn't I didn't give any
requirements what about number 10
really that's not for sure everyone
would write down 10 because that would
be the obvious order of execution
ceiling okay I feel like people aren't
maybe speaking up 9 9 do we have any 909
okay what's the condition
of Africa
oh man alright above average so alright
that's not gonna be possible but okay
that's it I like that one
one yes that's fine
nice I love it I love it I love it
three I'm and then that you did
understand that's just changing the game
three is chip shot Hey nice all right
make a mark on the whiteboard to win
did you provision for markers no I
didn't I know I'm running out of time
the six who wrote six down but you may
override the previous conditions no you
definitely okay oh okay all right
seven yes yeah blue okay and no wind
condition just reduce you said you wrote
seven or above you win what was what
were we on six or seven just now said oh
okay
and then I wrote down oh I was on three
so I skipped my turn and the first
person to be eliminated wins so so that
was you actually but that means random
so yeah but that I just wanted to kind
of do that because I think sometimes we
how many more minutes can't just count
down 60 you know so I think sometimes
when you when we go to a computer we
kind of our brain starts to separate and
we're like okay now we have to go and
code something and you sort of put the
horse before the cart before the horse
and it's important to think about like
that analog side of things of designing
a game basically from nothing I mean you
can take sheets of
and write down rules and then see how
they go together or you can roll some
dye and see how they they merge and so
it's important before you start coding
like really think about like what the
game is like where's the where's the
game that'll bring a lot of focus it'll
it'll tell you what to look up online
and you're thinking what do I need to do
first like what what what can i you know
I need to draw some graphics what
graphics well I don't know but have a
game in mind first that's that's the
thing that I wanted to illustrate so
thanks for coming to my talk and I hope
you got a lot out of it go by my blog
[Applause]